course à la direction du parti québécois
est ce que ça intéresse les jeunes fait
j'aimerais dire est-ce que ça intéresse
vraiment les jeunes parce que lors des
débats jusqu'ici les quatre candidats
ont souvent parlé des plus jeunes
générations
on dit que le parti québécois est un
parti de vieux vous êtes la solution il
faut arrêter d'être attentif puis de
regarder le train passer et c'est ça qui
va permettre à la jeunesse de prendre la
relève des jeunes péquistes ont moins de
poids au sein du pq que les jeunes
libéraux et le parti québécois doit
aussi faire le pont entre les
générations
on est à l'université laval pavillon
maurice-pollack qu'on va les voir
l'intérêt des étudiants
monsieur besson un feu n'ont vraiment
pas conçu simple baillargé l'entente du
district à radio pas mal pas mal parti
je vais m'y mettre mais pas question
quiz des quatre candidats ceux qui
occupent des chantiers police mon choix
riche héritière français alexandre jean
françois lisée puis merci nous aider
mais ça c'est sûr c'est véronique
mondiale est 4e dont le visage mais il
trace un peu à cela rien de cahiers
françois tela président du comité
national des jeunes du parti québécois
quoi ça puis on l'a vu là pourquoi ces
temps difficiles avait rejoint au pq les
jeunes les étudiants sur 40 20 40
je pense que c'est pas nécessairement
centre et au parti mais comme
questionnement comme problématique
comment se lancer des slogans devant les
jeunes c'est important on est parti la
jeunesse et tout mais concrètement ça se
répercute pas parce que le parti
québécois sa raison d'être
si c'est pas d'indépendance québec je
crois qu'ils devraient se tourner plus
sur des
en jeu - côté souverainiste il faudrait
que la cause environnementale
un côté de justice sociale pas très
référendum et pourquoi on en parle
autant si on veut autant dirigeants je
pense qu'il faut faire justement à
l'avenir au parti québécois c'est
consulter les jeunes ils savent ce
qu'est ce que ça change
concrètement dans la vie on aime
beaucoup de choses à dire mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'est pas tant un
côté faut dire que ce constat non
scientifique on s'entend pas seulement
ça ne date pas d'hier
en 2004 trois jeunes députés du parti
québécois était parti en tournée au
québec si j'ai pu universités pour
tenter de comprendre pourquoi les jeunes
quittent le parti québécois on les
appelait les trois mousquetaires et dans
le rapport on indiqué que les causes qui
préoccupait les jeunes
ce n'était pas celle de la souveraineté
mais bien davantage celle de
l'environnement ou encore des affaires
internationales jeudi laïcité ouais le
débat laïcité a perdu beaucoup d'heures
perdues coup de jeune
parce que c'était puisque je suis chez
lesquels des cantiques en avait parlé me
disait on doit avoir un projet inclusif
et endommagé attirant pour les lits pour
les immigrants et beaucoup des
distorsions des depuis les dernières
années dans le parti donc c'est un
président toujours avoir une directrice
on a arrêté d'évoluer on a arrêté de
faire évoluer le disco et titane et de
répondre ah c'était à ces questions se
posent aujourd'hui le stade va arriver
assez souvent et oui cette année oui
parce que c'est une question qui revient
tout le temps
en même temps c'est que quelque part on
n'a toujours pas trouvé la solution
finalement mais je pense qu'on la dit
quand donc y sont ils trop mobilisateur
qu'il veut changer les choses ariane
cayer merci beaucoup merci mon plâtre
merci à tous